Bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette vidéo.
Aujourd'hui on est chez Google au YouTube Space de Paris.
On est avec Chris, Fabien et Victor qui m'ont permis aujourd'hui de tourner entouré de fond vert.
Je suis dans le jeu, c'est la première fois de ma vie que j'suis dans un jeu vidéo.
C'est génial!
On va jouer à plusieurs jeux, en VR:
euh, des jeux de tirs, des jeux de baston, des jeux euh...
un peu chelous comme celui-ci.
(CLAP)
On est tis-par?
Là j'ai un délire depuis tout à l'heure, c'est de faire semblant de descendre de ce rebord.
(TADA)
Hééé!!!
Alors qu'en vrai c'est faux! C'est plat!
Je suis au même niveau!
Bon là on est dans un mini-jeu de The lab
Y a des gens qui vont attaquer ce château, faut que j'attaque ces gens qui vont attaquer le château.
C'est très simple hein?
J'ai mon arc -ici en chair et en os-.
Faut qu'je b**se lui...
(Epic Success)
Merci on applaudit!
(CLAP CLAP CLAP)
Merci à tous.
Bon allez c'est parti!
Donc lui c'est un barbare: il a une épée.
P*tain mais j'suis TE-LLE-MENT naze!
Mais c'était pas pratique à l'époque quand même les...(marmonnements)
Mec, ils arrivent. Ils sont énormément nooombreux!
Allez ça dégage. Oh le headshot!
(EPIC SUCCESS)
YES! Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire?
Le King surveille son village.
Ah j'suis en panique! J'suis en panique! J'suis le pire guerrier... (headshot)
Ok... J'ai retiré son casque.
Naaaan!
Nan!
NAN!
Nan...
(Essoufflement)
(Voix) : J'propose qu'on en profite pour te mettre un casque sur les oreilles.
(Squeezie) : C'est vrai ça! Mais c'est pour ça p*taaain! Les gars vous m'avez pas mis le son du jeuuuu...
Bah ouais... Comment tu veux que j'anticipe après?
Arf... J'suis hyper déçu.
Allez!
L'homme avec son drapeau... est décédé.
Regarde: je le tue d'ici! (success)
OH MAIS MEC! Nan mais franchement, appelez-moi "Arrow" quoi!
Appelez-moi "la série pour adolescents de 13 ans".
OH le mec met des feintes! P'tain mais j'en ai MARRE des mecs comme ça!
Ils m'ont fait CH**R au collège à l'Épervier, et ils continuent dans les jeux!
Une seule solution...
L'EXPLOSION!
(BOUM)
(Regard fier et hautain) Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire?
Headshot accross map? (fail)
Nan.
Alors on va faire par priorité...
Priorité aux mecs qui sont là... (success) Ok!
Ç... Nan nan nan! Touche pas à cette porte! Oh nan lui... la tête la tête!
(fail)
NAN!
Nan...
Oh m*rde!
Oh p*tain! Mais qu'est-ce  qu'il se passe?
Tu sais c'qui aurait été cool c'est qu'il y ait un ventilo qui simule le vent de la vallée.
(Blanc)
Personne m'écoute c'est pas grave.
Bon après avoir joué avec un arc et des flèches, on va jouer... avec The Rock!
Voilà... qui, euh, bide au cinéma, maintenant il est vigile dans un bar.
Excellent!
Par contre y a un problème... mon bras vous le voyez normal? D'accord.
Parce que... (rires)
Moi mec mes bras ils sont fusionnés ils sont comme ça (mime à l'écran)
(Rires)
Il f... J'pense qu'il est en train de mimer un doigt d'honneu... (fou rire)
(rires) WHAT THE FUCK?
Nan mais mec, les gars, vous m'faites jouer un gars déformé là!
Gnnn... En face y a des gars baraques qui me regardent trop mal,
moi j'suis là, j'les regarde en faisant ça quoi...
- Ouais, qu'est-ce que tu vas faire?
Eh le mec est immense! J'lui arrive...
aux tétés!
C'est incroyable.
Attends mais mec j'ai trop peur! Nan nan attends j'vais trouver le petit mec qui a...
Ah bah lui voilà, le mec qui phase bien cheum.
Toujours préparer le terrain avant de lancer une baston.
Règle numéro 1 créée par un mec qui ne s'est jamais battu... mais bon, c'est très bien.
(casse une bouteille)
BOOOOOOH!
Attention j'en reprends une...!
Ça marche pas!
AH IL M'A MIS UNE GRANDE CLAQUE!
... mais p*tain il m'fait peur! Mais pourquoi il joue à la mêlée? Arrête!
CASSE-TOI p*tain!
Ugnh ugnh ugnh... Laissez-le se relever!
Soyez fair-play les gars!
(envol et chute d'un gars)
(fou rire)
Qu'est-ce que tu fais? Qu'esse-tu-fais? Quessetufais? KESTUFAI?
Qu'est-ce-que tu fais mon gaaaars?
Voilà reste à terre! Reste à terre...
Esquive! Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire?
... vas-y tape dans la bouteille...
(la bouteille se casse)
(fou rire de Squeezie)
Mais pourquoi??
J'sa... mais franchement les gens d'ce bar...
J'sais pas c'que c'est ce bar, mais l'ambiance est un peu chelou quoi...
(lance une fléchette qui atterrit sur une fille)
Oh m... Pardooon! Oh pardon!
Mais nan en plus la seule fille cool du bar elle veut s'fight contre moi!
Atten-ten-ten-ten-tends...
Mais toi casse-toi!
(lance une autre fléchette qui atterrit sur une autre fille)
M****RDE LA DEUXIÈME MEUF!
La deuxième... (rires)
AH! Pardon!
Excuse-moi! (rires)
Ah mais en fait j'suis mort!
En fait j'suis mort j'avais pas fait gaffe. (rires)
Ça c'est moi en fait.
Ma vie actuellement... hein...
(montre le corps du joueur à terre)
BON! De retour pour n*quer des mères!
-et j'parle de la tienne.
Bon mec j'vais m'armer jusqu'aux dents!
(prends un tabouret)
Oh ouaaaaais....
Alors là... alors LÀ mon pote!
Deux d'un coup...
BAAAAAAAH
(fou rire)
Merde ma cam...
NAN!
Casse-toi!
D'où tu m'fais un f*ck? D'où tu m'fais un f*ck?
T'es qui toi?
T'es qui dans l'e-sport ?
J'te b**se!
Oh m*rde! J'suis en train d'embrouiller tout l'bar.
Qu'est-ce qu'il fait? Qu'est-ce qu'il... c'est quoi cet endroit?
Mais tout allait bien jusqu'à ce que tu fasses ça!
Non mais aidez-le!
Nan laisse-moi t'aider... laisse-moi t'relever...
Pardon!
Nan j'veux juste t'aider! Pardon!
Mais p*tain c'est contagieux ou quoi là?
J'veux t'aider mais j'crois que j'peux juste te taper.
J'veux t'aider... j-j'suis en train de t'aider!
J'vais t'aider, j'vais t'aider...
Mais tu fais quoi toi?
Le mec il s'incruste dans l'embrouille, ça dégage direct!
J'ai entendu un p'tit conseil: je serai plus fort si je bois.
Y a une voix-off qui a dit ça...
Parce que j'suis bilingue j'parle régulièrement anglais.
Mec, j'peux te dire que là... on va enchaîner.
(bois)
Ça, c'est fait.
Là, si j'nique pas des mères...
franchement, désolé de l'dire...
mais c'est qu'il y a un gros problème.
T'sais quoi? On fait un 1vs1.
Alors quand y a pas ton pote pour t'aider tu fais MOINS le malin!
LES BOULES MON POTE! Les boules!
Franck Ropers Academy, hein! (rires)
ÇA c'est la puissance de Franck.
Voilà il fait une crise d'épilepsie. Voilà, ils partent en danse... i-il part en break-dance.
Mais il danse hyper bien le c*n p*tain!
Bon bah voilà! J'pense... j'considère que j't'ai battu.
Sans rancune!
POOOOOH
Oh mais mec quoi... (rires)
Il m'fait peur en vrai!
Il f... Sauf quand il fait ça!
Quand il fait ça, j'ai plus peur.
'tends 'tends j'l'attends...
J'le surprends!
J'le surprends dans les boules! Frank Roberts!
... c'est vrai que quand j'bois j'suis fort hein!
Eh mais lui par contre j'crois que j'ai vraiment cassé son cerveau.
Il a vraiment un gros problème.
Bon allez, p'tite bière!
P'tite bière, on va s'poser sur le tabouret.
(fail)
(rires)
Ça marche pas du tout! Ça marche pas du tout!
Ok les gars faut qu'on s'venge... sur ces mesdames.
(fixe une femme)
Alors? Tu m'as mal parlé tout à l'heure?
J'aimerais qu'tu baisses les yeux quand j'te parle s'il-te-plaît.
Oh m*rde pardon!
M*rde! Elle est super venere la daronne mon gars, elle s'bat mieux qu'les hommes!
(Voix) : Ohlala elle tape des esquives!
(Squeezie) : Haha, mec elle marche plus très droit! (rires)
Elle part en danse.
Nan nan nan par contre elle, avec son high-kick de merde, ça dégage!
Eh j'me bats comme un enfant quoi!
UGHNNN
HUNNN j'sais pas si j'f... OH!
(rires)
OH NAN!
Nan nan, relève-toi, relève-toi, relève-toi bonhomme!
Tout va bien s'passer!
Relève-toi, relève-toi!
(rires)
Comment tu veux que j'revive mec avec ce système?
Bonjour bonjour! Je suis l'homme qui va casser des c*e et n*quer des mères.
J'vais tiser un p'tit peu avant.
(bois)
Et là on est parés, on s'approche doucement.
En pose de lion.
Et là les amis, Frank Roberts c'est quoi?
C'est deux testicules: un à gauche, un à droite...
... et on TAPE dedans!
Moi j'fais des techniques de b*tard mon gars!
Voilà, là il arrive pas à m'atteindre, là je le balaie,
et là coup dans les boules et c'est normal.
Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire, qu'est-ce que tu vas faire?
(rires) Il se fait embrouiller par un autre
(rires)
Hop-là, ni vu ni connu, l’anaconda on l’appelle
Hop-là, allez ça dégage.
Hop-là, et ouais mon pote!
Eh....
On fait le train?
Eh bien bonjour et bienvenue dans mon échoppe, dans mon Konbini, hein!
Allez, j'vous lâche plus avec le Japon, c'est terrible. C'est terrible!
"Konbini" au Japon c'est des magasins qui sont ouverts 24h/24, 7j/7.
Est-ce qu'on est là pour parler du Japon?
Non.
Allez c'est parti!
Client suivant! Vous connaissez le jeu, c'est le tout premier auquel on a joué en VR.
Ah nan, c'était l'deuxième.
Je sais plus! J'suis un Youtubeur de m*rde, voilà je sais plus!
Alors on accueille un client...
Est-ce que j'peux lui voler sa pipe?
Oh p***tain!
Ça c'est une très belle journée!
(fait semblant de fumer la pipe)
Alors il veut quoi?
J-j'ai pas écouté...
Il veut p'tet sa pipe du coup, juste?
(tend la pipe)
(fail)
La réponse est non!
Mais attends mec si ça se trouve en vrai il veut juste un truc, genre euh tout c*n, mec.
Soit il veut juste ça.
(blanc)
Ça veut dire quoi ça?
Mais mec quand tu viens dans un Supermarché, tu ne t'adresses pas au caissier en lui disant "frère donne-moi c'que tu veux"!
C'est toi qui arrive et qui lui donne c'que tu veux acheter!
Est-ce que... est-ce que j'lui file un Burrito? Ça fait l'taff, nan, un Burrito les gars vous en pensez quoi?
Moi j'trouve ça pas mal.
M... il prend tout! Le mec prend tout!
Un bon Bretzel, mon gars!
Il le prend!
Il prend tout!
Fais péter l'cash.
(tente un "throwing money")
(fail)
(rires)
Ça marche pas p*tain!
Allez client suivant.
On arrête les c*nneries.
Ok...
Oui oui Lunettes, dis-moi tout.
(le personnage parle)
Qu'est-ce qu'il dit?
Quelqu'un comprend ce qu'il dit?
Ah j'crois qu'il est en train d'faire une crise d'hypoglycémie mec. Il a pas assez de sucre.
De la glace bleue bien chimique!
C'est pour toi mon... attends atten-ten-tends!
Nan mais nan mais j'l'ai pas scannée avant mec!
J'l'ai pas scannée avant! P*tain j'me suis fait douiller...
Et bah moi HOP-LÀ j'te prends tes lunettes en... en échange!
Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire? J't'ai volé tes lunettes mon pote! (rires)
Alors qui j'me tape?
Oh p*tain...
C'est un braquage?!
(prends la banane du braqueur)
Va-t'en!
Attends j'lui ai... P*tain meeec...
Frank Roberts quoi...
J'connais bien la baston, on l'a bien vu!
Le gars j'lui ai fait...
(fail)
Quoi?
Comment il a fait pour ré-avoir un gun?
Ok! (rires)
Ok le coffre il est  où?
Il est là, c'est bon il est là. Il est là. J'ai l'coffre, j'ai l'coffre, j'ai l'coffre, c'est bon tire pas dessus.
Tiens, tiens. J'te donne tous mes lingots d'fromage...
Allez va-t'en!
(chope la banane du voleur à nouveau)
HOP-LÀ Frank Roberts!
(rires)
J'aime trop cette vanne!
Ok suivant!
Il... C'est vraiment le meilleur jeu en VR.
Franchement hein, est-ce qu'au fond d'nous, on a pas tous toujours eu envie d'être caissier, finalement?
Bon alors, client suivant!
Oooooh les vilains! Ils veulent acheter de l'alcool, ils font semblant!
J'peux voir votre carte d'identité?
Est-ce que ce n'est pas une fausse carte d'identité?
(BIP)
Bon apparemment, le... euh le scanner croit que c'est un vrai adulte.
Ils veulent quoi?
Ils veulent des pétards p*tain!
Ils veulent des Bisons 4.
Eh attends comment j'ouvre?
Ah d'accord, c'est carrément mis sous clef et tout.
Oh p*tain mais mec c'est du Bison 8?!
M**RDE!
M*rde! Tiens, tiens, tiens c'est pour toi!
C'est pour toi, tiens! (rires)
Prends le feu d'artifice, prends-le!
Bon bref, ils veulent ça, et ils veulent... ça.
Mais nan mais mec!
Mais c'est pas possible là!
Ça va faire quoi? Ça va pé... attends, ça va péter sale?
(blanc)
C'est super long hein!
Ah mais c'est juste une... d'accooord!
C'est juste une... tu sais c'qu'il y a sur les gâteaux quoi!
Allez, prenez les gars!
(voix du personnage)
OH! Oh, imposteur!
Bande d'enc*lééés!
Tiens! Va-t'en!
P*taaain...
À chaque fois j'me fait avoir, j'en ai marre...
C'est fini?!
Mais ce jeu était trop bien!
On s'est jamais autant amusés ch... au YouTube Space!
Mais viens Victor, viens, n'hésite pas, viens!
Viens dans mon échoppe, vas-y, viens y a pas de soucis tu peux venir!
Attention...
Ah! C'est bon!
Alors, qu'est-ce que vous voulez? (fou rire)
On a 8 ans quoi, c'est génial!
Qu'est-ce que tu veux? De l'alcool?
Alors attends, frère, tu vas pas être déçu.
Tiens frère, c'est de l'alcool.
(Victor) : Merci hein, euh, par contre j'ai pas de monnaie...
(Squeezie) : T'as pas de monnaie?
(Victor) : Ouais je vais...
(Squeezie) : POLICE! Police!